[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance the first coverage of the
many scandals of the Trump
administration was published on July
12th 1973 1973 you may have seen this
reproduced on social media it is by the
Pulitzer prize-winning 50 years
syndicated political columnist and
satirist Art Buchwald and of course it
wasn't really about Trump and Russia and
Trump and the election and Trump and
possible obstruction of justice
except that about 90% of it holds up
word-for-word 44 years and one month
later about an entirely different
presidential nightmare in an entirely
different America Art Buchwald was
writing about Richard Nixon and
Watergate his column was based at the
Washington Post and at its height it was
syndicated to 550 newspapers the author
never made Nixon's enemies list he
reportedly said that was his greatest
regret but long after his death in 2007
it turned out the National Security
Administration the NSA had spied on art
buchwald probably at the behest not of
Nixon but of President Lyndon Johnson
who didn't like him either
anyway what Buckwald offered the post
for publication on Thursday July 12th
1973 more than a month before we knew
there were Watergate tapes longer still
before we knew John Dean was telling the
truth and Nixon was not for months
before Nixon insisted he was quote not a
crook a year in 27 days before Nixon
resigned it holds up almost entirely as
an analysis of the defenses of Donald
Trump a quick search at the
newspapers.com website shows the column
was published by at least 27 newspapers
that day at least 11 more than X at
least 15 more in the next week and by at
least two more stragglers as late as the
23rd of July it appeared in every size
and shape of American newspaper from the
post to the Los Angeles Times to the
Detroit Free Press to the oil city Derek
of oil city Pennsylvania if you're not
old enough or not enough of a student of
American political history to know the
old stuff the only Watergate irid detail
you really need to know
to appreciate this column is the 1969
drunk driving incident in which Senator
Ted Kennedy's passenger Mary Jo Kopechne
II was killed at Chappaquiddick Island
in Massachusetts some have tried to
update the Buckwald column to put in
trumpian references it doesn't quite
work that we will offer a few updates by
the use of illustrations so in homage
and gratitude to buckwalds great
political insight to say nothing of his
remarkable post mortem political
foresight
I will now read this column which
appeared under a variety of titles most
of which were variations on the one in
Los Angeles oh yeah what about
Chappaquiddick these are difficult times
for people who are defending the Nixon
administration no matter where they go
they are attacked by pseudo liberals
McGovern lovers heterosexual
constitutionalists and paranoid John
Dean believers as a public service I am
printing instant responses for loyal
Nicks and nights when they are attacked
at a party please cut it out and carry
it in your pocket one
everyone does it - what about
Chappaquiddick three a president can't
keep track of everything his staff does
for the press is blowing the whole thing
up five whatever Nixon did was for
national security six the Democrats are
sore because they lost the election
seven are you gonna believe a rat like
John Dean or the President of the United
States eight wait til all the facts come
out nine what about Chappaquiddick 10 if
you impeach Nixon you get Agnew 11 the
only thing wrong with Watergate is they
got caught 12 what about Daniel Ellsberg
stealing the Pentagon Papers 13 it
happens in Europe all the time 14 people
would be against Nixon no matter what he
did
15 I'd rather have a crook in the White
House than a fool 16 LBJ used to read
FBI reports every
right 17 what's the big deal about
finding out what your opposition is up
to 18 the president was too busy running
the country to know what was going on 19
what about Chappaquiddick 20 people who
live in glass houses shouldn't throw
stones 21 McGovern would have lost
anyway 22 maybe the committee for the
re-election of the president went a
little too far but they were just a
bunch of eager kids 23 I'm not for
breaking any law but sometimes you have
to do it to save the country 24 Nixon
made a mistake he's only human
25 do you realize what Watergate is
doing to the dollar abroad 26 what about
Harry Truman in the Deep Freeze scandal
27 Franklin D Roosevelt did a lot of
worse things 28 I'm sick and tired of
hearing about Watergate and so is
everybody else
29 this thing should be tried in the
courts and not on television 30 when
Nixon gives his explanation of what
happened there are gonna be a lot of
people in this country with Ag on their
faces 31 my country right or wrong 32
what about Chappaquiddick 33 I think the
people who make all this fuss about
Watergate should be shot 34 if the
Democrats had the money they would have
done the same thing
35 I never trusted Haldeman and
Ehrlichman to start with 36 if you say
one more word about Watergate I'll punch
you in the nose 36 a if the person is
bigger than you if you say one more word
about Watergate I'm leaving this house
36 B if it's your own house and the
person is bigger than you what about
Chappaquiddick by part Buckwald it is
safe to say that in 1973 Donald Trump
did not read this column in ruminating
on buckwalds number 17 what's the big
deal about finding out what your
position is up - it is safe to say that
nobody in the Trump campaign ever read
this column and it is safe to guess that
word Trump himself confronted with
buckwalds masterpiece today his
likeliest response would be that art
buchwald is an example of somebody who's
done an amazing job and is getting
recognized more and more I noticed and
why isn't he writing about crooked
Hillary resists remove piece